thank you feeling a lot of emotions  right now I'm Shawn  I'm from hello games we're a tiny little  indie studio we're a group of friends  making no man sky it's a science fiction  game I guess inspired by the kind of  sci-fi that I grew up with the battered  book covers of Heinlein Asimov Clark  just worlds that I wanted to escape to  but never could we've created a  procedural universe it's infinite and  it's one that everyone can share we're  going to start every player on a  different planet so no two people will  have the same experience this universe  that we've created it's it's so vast  it's so boundless it's actually infinite  and we don't even know what's out there  when the game releases every player who  picks up a pad and plays is going to  help us discover a little bit more and I  can't wait I want to finish with just a  tiny taste of what your own unique  journey into infinity might look like  hope you like it